yeah I know what to welcome home to this
video tour which 57
it's my opponent yeah you never know
sometimes they don't play into the
Scotch for Knights but rather go for
Bishop c5 yeah it was close pretty for
like him
it's amazing that you get this M and
it's pretty pretty awful for black and
no one to be awful for a very long time
there are some tricks a Queen f6 King G
one Knight G form things like that I
talked about that in the earlier blitz
video that like when this is released
probably that was on a couple of days
before it's the best way to develop not
the only one quite clearly you have some
some leader here with the big center and
and the pair of bishops a little bit do
we add everything yeah it doesn't work
you know I can take one g7 at the end
why is that working now Queen f6 Kingi
one okay so I check here yeah well okay
can play Queen f6 but I don't my dad
that's actually I'd actually worse than
up yet I think after Bishop g5 I get the
bishop to f6 and that's pretty much the
end of the game if the bishop lens on f6
it's just not going to be survivable
this position
as Blackie cannot cannot cancel either
side okay Bishop f6 there's Queen h6
okay so I can play then check on e 2 and
d5 which it's pretty awful but just
wonder if this if I can do something
even better
Bishop f6 is not not strictly necessary
Queen e2 should be six d5 you know it's
probably none stronger
after takes and I takes Knight f6
chicken is pretty pretty awful yeah but
it doesn't help him all that much I was
thinking
look do you want will come
[Music]
and still still no really Rock g1
or Bishop f6 Bishop f6 is also not bad
yeah but the risk of t1
what does he want to give the Queen I'm
not quite certain what's the point is
what Oh Bishop g4 maybe stuck the idea
hmm
yeah here's this rook f4 I'm not sure if
this is helping a lot but it's possible
I look to deform
I forgot that after pawn takes that the
rook takes your father's check um anyway
I can move the King read the Queen is
still attacked
yeah and the bishop would be would be
really nice on f6 can I do something
else though he will take one d5 with the
rook yeah I don't know this looks pretty
good
the knight now is hanging and where does
it go here okay
yeah then loop key 448 maid I probably
played that no really we get fashion but
the position was just too bad I think so
I couldn't screw it up
yeah like lost on time here but yeah
okay yeah we should c5 is just not a
good move if black plays perfectly after
it he's only a slightly worse but yeah
yeah here Queen f6 is tricky but if you
were if you search for three nights game
or something
you would probably find the game that I
mentioned where I explained things about
it yeah I know c6 after he five looks
lost
really yeah plus two okay
d5 these eggs takes Queen f6 and yeah
Bishop g5 looks them but I I didn't do
it right here I should play at just 94
here not sure why I didn't do that
it's totally winning but okay it's not
like that doesn't win but it is not as
convincing and I should play Bishop f6
first and only then he and I this is
really less precise you know like it's
somewhat in the game again 95
okay foyer this is not a king edge one
winning senator the Queen has no good
square the opieop f6 the knight is
hanging it has no squares really and
rook t form is deadly I know route d8
made you cannot stop it simply this is
some if you give the comp enough time it
will show mate for sure I don't think he
can escape the mate in the long run I
know it gets higher and higher probably
you just need a little bit of time then
then it will show made in a door
whatever ten can no idea okay guys
thanks for watching